ゲームショーホストのシャン：ようこそ、「これって本当にあるセックスのこと？」へ！さて、
最初で唯一の質問です。次のうち、実在しないセックスのことはどれでしょう？
足に興奮すること。セックス中にチョコレートやホイップクリームなどの食べ物を使うこと。
そして、セックス中に目隠しされることを楽しむこと。
[観客が息を呑む]
これはひっかけ問題です！全部、本当にあるセックスのことなんです。
こんにちは、私はシャン・ブードラムです。これはクラッシュ・コース・セックスエド。今日は
キンク――そしてそれがどれほど一般的なのかについて話します。コマーシャルの後、すぐ戻ります。
[テーマ音楽]
キンクとは、伝統的ではない性的な行動や欲望――
たとえば、セックス中に見られることが好きだったり、ゴム製の服に夢中だったりすることです。
こうした欲望は、妄想の世界の中だけにある場合もあります。
頭の中で想像するだけで興奮して、実際に行動には移さないこともあります。
一方で、それらの欲望が実際のセックスライフの一部になっている場合もあります。
私たちの文化ではよく、キンクのことをタコベルのホットソースのディアブロレベルのように思いがちです。
「マイルドは大衆向け。本当に辛いのが好きな人は少ない。」みたいな感じです。
でも実は…多くの人が
辛いもの――つまりキンクを楽しんでいるんです。キンクって、思っているよりずっと普通なんですよ。
初回エピソードで学んだ通り、どの性的表現が
「普通」かは、自分たちの住む時代や場所によって形作られます。実際のところ、
性や性的行動に関して言えば、多様性こそが普通なんです。
例えば、カナダ、イタリア、アメリカの3つの研究を見てみましょう。調査を受けたカナダ人の
半数以上が、公共の場でセックスしたり支配されたりする妄想をしたことがあると答えました。
イタリア人の68％が、一度はキンクな妄想をしたことがあると答えています。
最も多かったのは、ボヤリズム――誰かが服を脱いだり
裸になったり、性的なことをしている様子を見て興奮することです。
そして調査を受けたアメリカ人の90％以上が、
支配されたりパートナーを支配したりする妄想をしたことがあると答えました。
ちなみにこの調査は「フィフティ・シェイズ・オブ・グレイ」の上映中に映画館で行われたわけではありません。
「でも、どうしてなの、シャン？」そんな声が聞こえてきます。なぜ痛みを好む人がいるのか、触手プレイとか、
おむつをはくのが好きな人がいるのか？なぜ君はキンキーなんだ？
実のところ、他の性に関する話題と比べて
キンクについての研究はあまり多くありません。でもこれまでに行われた研究からすると、理由はたくさんあるかもしれません！
ひとつの仮説として、キンクは学習されるもの――
まるでパブロフの犬が、夕飯の音とベルの音を結びつけて、ベルを聞いただけでよだれをたらしたような感じです。
ときどき、単純な快感の経験に、セクシーとは思えないものが一緒に絡むと、
その物に性的興奮が結びつくことがあります。するとほら、キンクの誕生です。
ある種のキンクは、内向的とか外向的といった性格特性と関係している場合もあります。そしてこれらの特性は遺伝の影響も受けます。ただ、このデータは
特に限られています――こういうことを研究者が人にあまり聞いてこなかったんですね！
このような性的な興味が「フェティッシュ」と呼ばれるのを耳にしたことがあるかもしれません。
でも、フェティッシュとキンクは同じものではありません。キンクは広く言えばタブーとされる性的な行動を指しますが、
実際にはそんなに珍しいことではない場合もあります。
一方で、フェティッシュは特定のタイプのキンクで、誰かが
レザーや下着などの特定の物や、髪や足など非生殖器の身体の一部に性的興奮を感じる場合です。
いずれにせよ、2017年のある研究によると、フェティッシュがある人でも
それだけがセックスのやり方ではありません。ただ、その方法が特に好きなだけなんです。
でもここで注意！ディアブロソースやマンゴーハバネロ、あるいはダ・ボムみたいなのが
自分の好みじゃないと、「うわぁ…」と思って、それが好きな人をついジャッジしがちです。
そのせいで、フェティッシュを持つ人がパートナーにそれを打ち明けるのをためらうことがあるんです。
でも、関わるみんなが同意していれば、キンクやフェティッシュはセックスにおいて楽しくて満足感のある要素になり得ます。
例えば、大きな例を挙げると…よく誤解されがちなキンクにBDSMがあります。
定義は時代とともに変わってきましたが、今では、
一般的にボンデージ、ディシプリンとサブミッション、
そしてサディズムとマゾヒズム―パワーダイナミクスや痛みのやりとりを楽しむセックス行為、を指すと理解されています。
驚くかもしれませんが、「イタッ」が「ウフフ」にどう変わるの？と思いますよね。ええと、
実は、快感と痛みの処理は脳内でかなり密接に関連しているという証拠があるんです。
どちらもオピオイドやドーパミン系に関わっているため、脳で複雑に絡み合っています。
でも、痛みをプレイするには注意が必要です。調査では、
BDSMの活動で故意にせよ事故にせよ、ケガが起きることがあると示されています。
しかし、BDSMコミュニティは同意と安全性をとても重視しています。
良いBDSMの実践では、始める前に「何をするか」「何はNGか」をきちんと話し合うこと、
そして「セーフワード」を使い、いつでも即座に行為を止められるようにすること、
さらに徐々にトーンダウンして、思いやりや優しさに戻ることが大切です。
多くの人にとって、痛みが快感になるのは、その痛みに意味があるからです。中には
BDSMを楽しむ人たちが、痛みとのコントラストで快感がより強く感じられると言っています。
つまり、チョコチップクッキーに塩を足して甘さが際立つみたいな感じですね。
それに、BDSMが必ずしもセックスするためのものとは限りません！多くの人にとっては、
力を手放す、もしくは力を持つこと自体が魅力となっています。
これは日常生活であまり体験できない、「パワー・エクスチェンジ」と呼ばれる遊び方です。
ファーリーズも同じです―アートや
物語、または「ファースーツ」と呼ばれる衣装を着て「ファーソナ」としてヒト化動物になりきってロールプレイする人々です。
ファーリーズの中には、それが多少セクシャルな意味を持つ人もいますが、必ずしもそうではありません！その魅力は、
創造力を働かせたり、普段の自分をしばらく脱ぎ捨てて自由になることだったりします。
セックスが関係していようとなかろうと、魅力を感じる人がいるのです。
理由はどうあれ、人間はとにかくキンクに走るもの。でも、「楽しい
スパイシーなタコスのトッピング」から「なんでこんなに辛いソース作るの？！」と思うくらいまで、
キンクが問題になるのはどこからでしょうか？
それは場合によります。どんなに良いことでも、行き過ぎれば問題になることがあります。
でも、その境界線がどこなのかはとても複雑です。
いわゆる「異常」とされる性的嗜好自体は、本来悪いものではありません。DSM-5、
アメリカ精神医学会が精神疾患の分類や診断の基準として使うガイドラインでは、
パラフィリア（“パラ”は「超える」、「フィリア」は「愛着」）という用語で
「同意した大人同士の間に強烈で持続的な性的関心があること」を
表現しています。それ自体は、必ずしも問題ではありません。
ただし、そのパラフィリアが本人や
他人に苦痛や害をもたらす場合、DSM-5ではそれを「パラフィリック障害」と分類します。この場合、
カウンセラーの紹介や処方薬が勧められることもあります。
ただし、どの行動を「障害」と分類するかは課題が多いと専門家は警告していて、
何が「普通」かは文化や社会的状況によって変わることが多いからです。だから
パラフィリック障害の分類を明確にするため、さらなる研究の必要性が指摘されています。
キンクはみんな向きじゃありません。もしそうなら、キンクじゃなくなっちゃいますよね！でも、
多くの人が「変わってる」と思うようなものも、実はそこまで珍しくないんです。
セックスに関して私たちがすること、考えること、感じることは、自分自身の表現でもありますが、
同時に私たちが生きる時代や環境にも左右されます。
結局、セクシュアリティとはおいしくて多様なもの。それはこのシリーズ全体で
何度も繰り返してきたテーマです。ある人の「やってみたい！」が
別の人には「結構です」かもしれません。
でも、それってすごくワクワクしませんか？同じように感じるパートナーと
一緒に最高の時間を過ごせる余地がちゃんとある。そして、新しいことにチャレンジし続けられる場所もあるのです。
または定番のお気に入りに戻るのもアリです。
レシピが何であれ、良いセックスの基本的な要素は同じです。
同意があって、安全で、みんなの間に信頼と楽しさ、喜びがあることです。
ということで…クラッシュ・コース・セックスエド、これにて終了！
ティーン・シャン、今の気分はどう？
ティーン・シャン：かなりスッキリしました。ありがとう、オールド・シャン！
シャン：ねぇ、誰のことを“オールド”って言ってるのよ？
ティーン・シャン：あっ、ごめん。帰り道にもう一つコンドーム風船いかが？
このクラッシュ・コース・セックスエドのエピソードは、
インディアナ大学キンセイ研究所とのパートナーシップで制作されました。もっと知りたい方は、
今日の動画で扱ったトピックを探究できるリソースがウェブサイトにありますので、ご覧ください。
今回のエピソードをご視聴いただきありがとうございます。インディアナポリスのスタジオで収録し、
これらの才能あふれる人たちの協力で作られました。もしよろしければ、
クラッシュ・コースをみんながずっと無料で学べるよう、ぜひPatreonで私たちのコミュニティにご参加ください。